cette société de location de matériel
audiovisuel dédié à l'événementiel avec
son activité arrêtée dès le premier
confirmant tout le matériel d'or sur les
étagères puisqu'il n'y a plus de
réunions possibles sur 10 appels
feuilles avait dit de vie fait
pratiquement huit affaires conclues et
tout s'est arrêté net à partir du 14
mars
plus aucune affaire plus aucun dossier
un plan social a donc dû être mise en
place sur 47 salariés vent postes ont
été supprimés ainsi qu'une antenne à
toulouse leur chiffre d'affaires a été
divisé par deux en 2019 il avait réalisé
12 millions d'euros seulement 7 millions
en 2020 pour continuer une certaine
activité les salariés ont créé en studio
de 180 m² avec un mur de l'aide dans
leur partie dépôt pour pouvoir le
proposer à la location
ici vous avez un grand écran led qui
permet de faire de la communication des
entreprises de communication interne
vous avez derrière mais le plateau
caméra
et nous en voyons tout ça sur le sur
internet par le biais du streaming avec
une plateforme digitale ce sont des
nodal les salariés par le biais de cette
plateforme
vous récupérez les flux de
visioconférence par exemple et ça c'est
de la solution d'entre eux pour prier
avec les caisses que ça marche plutôt
bien et on a d'excellents retours de nos
clients mais cela ne suffira pas pour
payer toutes les charges
la société a donc fait appel aux séries
p le centre d'information sur la
prévention des difficultés des
entreprises
on a rendez vous avec trois
professionnels dont un ancien juge du
tribunal de commerce de versailles alors
à exposer notre notre situation
ils nous ont donné des conseils qu'on a
appliqué ces entretiens ont eu lieu deux
jeudis par mois en général 50 entretiens
ont été réalisés en une année en 2020 il
y en a eu plus de 80 en 2021 j'ai vu moi
- mouche est persuadé qu'il va y avoir
un boom ladder d'entreprises en
difficulté mais quand il y avait qu ils
vont commencer à faire leurs premiers
bilans et leurs premières prévisions de
trésorerie mais que ça va tomber dans le
rouge
forcément ils vendent bien souvent la
cgt prévoit déjà d' instaurer des rendez
vous supplémentaire en 2021 pour gérer
l'afflux des entreprises en difficulté